the Joe Rogan experience no it doesn't
make any sense I was reading something
where people are going after tells he
gathered for being on Tucker Carlson
she's like I'll talk to everybody and
I'm glad she does and by the way it's
like it's hard for her because she's
kind of an outside candidate it's hard
for her to get time on these other
networks and so they want to punish her
for being on Tucker Carlson's and then
they have this you know reductionist
view of who he is he's a white
supremacist like to all she supports
white supremacists she goes on a white
supremacist show it okay is that what he
is really what he is and he's it's neat
a lot more than that there's a lot going
on there right you guys are [ __ ] with
life you know you're [ __ ] with the
reality of life and you're saying it in
these sentences you're printing it out
and these paragraphs as fact and you
sending it out there irresponsibly and
it's just really strange that people
don't understand the repercussions of
that yeah there's something we talked
about on our podcast easily it's all the
time is that the this it's a catch-22
right like you you don't invite somebody
like Tulsi Gabbard on to CNN MSNBC where
you they're kind of excluded from the
same platform the other politicians get
so they go to other platforms all right
and then you say oh you went on that
platform so you're illegitimate yes you
know what do you want them to do like
you or they do the same thing with
people who go on RT for instance right
oh well you're helping the Russians
because you went on RT well there that's
because you didn't invite them on any I
mean yeah you people are gonna try to
talk to anybody they can to spread their
ideas and that that that kind of
propaganda thing is is pretty constant
now in the use of the term terms like
what white supremacists with Tucker
Carlson I mean there are there are a
million terms now that you use to just
kind of throw at people and what they're
trying to do is create this ik factor
around people yeah right like once you
get someone gets a label associated with
them then nobody wants to be associated
with that person right right and they
quickly kind of die out of the public
scene and that's I think that's really
bad too you know it's it's like a
the it's it's just an anti-intellectual
way of dealing with things and I and I
think it's it's not good it's weird that
it's so prevalent that's weird that
there's so few proponents of a more you
know open-minded way of thinking right
yeah and just to take the gap we had we
had Tulsa together on our show too and
immediately we got accused what do you
love Assad right do you want a bomb Siri
and sure you want to keep murder Cyril
no I you know she's a presidential
candidate you know we want to talk to
wanna hear what she has to say
but they immediately go to the
maximalist interpretation of everything
and then they're what they're basically
saying when they ask you those questions
are do you want to wear that label too
because she's got it already so if you
have a run again you're gonna you're
you're gonna have that label and people
they see that you know and and so you
know people who have who don't have a
big following and who are who are
worried about their careers and about
you know the money and advertisers and
stuff like that they they think twice
about you know interviewing that person
the next time yeah and is another way to
get that speech exactly and again I
don't know how you get out of it you
know and I mean I've experienced some
blowback I guess but it doesn't hasn't
worked yet right you know I mean it's
not real it's like it's just words like
okay well but yeah and and but you're
handling it the right way Ben yeah I
think people your audience is rewarding
you for for not not bowing to it you
know and I think that more people if
they took that example and said I'm not
gonna listen to what the the pack says
about this I'm not gonna be afraid of
being called a name you know [ __ ] that
I'm gonna talk to what I want to talk to
and I'm gonna gonna have you know
explore whatever ideas I want to explore
then this kind of stuff wouldn't be as
effective so yeah so easy to do to
people it's so easy too deep for them
too deep platform people yes so easy and
shadow banning and all this other weird
[ __ ] that's going on yeah they're
channeling people and and pushing people
into these areas of
platforms that makes him less accessible
and I know where it comes from you know
I was I was young and politically active
once you know you you want to change the
world you want to make it a better place
so you're in college and you don't have
any power you don't have any way to
input make something into legislation
you know what I mean you so what do you
do you you you know social media gives
you the illusion that you're having an
impact in the world by you know maybe
getting somebody deep platformed or
taken off twitter or something like that
it feels like it's political action that
yeah but it's not you know what I mean
it's it's it's something that they that
is open to people to do but it's not the
same as you know getting 60 Congress 60
members of the Senate to to raise taxes
on a corporation that's been evading
them for 20 years you know what I mean
like that's that's real action this you
know getting some random person taken
off the internet is just not change you
know but but people feel like it is and
and they wanna they want to do the right
thing so I get it but no it's it's not
you know a real political action I don't
think no it's [ __ ] gross yeah and it
just lead it's there's so much of it on
there so little logic
[Applause]